Now, for anybody that's not aware, what Niagara is, is, well, it's very simple.
Niagara is a tool for creating visual effects inside of Unreal Engine 5.
With Niagara, you can create anything from a simple smoke to an interactive crowd simulation.
Niagara is also built for everyone in need of visual effects, whether you work in architectural
visualization, you just need maybe a simple something for ambience, or you work in industrial
design such as automotive designs, and you need to use some visual effects to heighten
your user interface, or maybe possibly add some tire smoke, or maybe you work in virtual
TV and film production, and you need some magical spells, or maybe in video games where
there's all types of different effects.
Unreal's Niagara system is going to be where you can create all of this different type
of effects for whatever your needs happen to be.
And here are some great examples of things that you can create with Niagara.
Now, these are taken right from the content examples, which we'll cover here in the next
slide, but what these are showing is just the absolute insanity that you can make with
this tool.
It is extremely powerful.
And what we have here is we actually have particles that are spawning on the surface
of a skeletal mesh.
We have the beginning of a fluid simulation.
We also have on the right hand side particles that react to the light.
That's right.
As that light shines across that face right there, those bugs are going to move around
and scurry to get out of the way of the light.
And this is all done through Niagara.
And you can see just from this images that this is a very powerful tool.
So we'll show you some stuff you can do in the content examples.
You're going to see why Niagara is such a great tool for you to learn how to use.